افاد مراسل الجزيره بسقوط عدد من الشهداء
في حي الصفطاوي شمال قطاع غزه وص انبا عن
قيام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بتدمير
واحراق منازل في
المنطقه من مخيم جباليه شماليه قطاع غزه
معنا الصحفي عماد زقوط اهلا بك عماد اذا
ما اخر المعلومات المتوفره لديك حول ما
يجري
ميدانيا نعم المدفعيه الاسرائيليه هي
تواصل قصفه لمناطق متفرقه من شمال قطع غزه
تحديدا في المناطق الشرقيه لجبال تحديدا
منطقه الجرم وزم هذه المنطقتين تعرضتا
لقصف مكثف من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
على مدار الليله الماضيه حتى هذه اللحظه
كذلك هنالك في منطقه الصفطاوي وهذا حي
كبير يتكون من العديد من العمارات
السكانيه التي تتكون كل عماره من خمسه
طوابق هذه العمارات تعرضت لاحراق وايضا
لتفجير من قبل جنود الاحتلال والاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي تتمركز في تلك
المناطق ايضا المسيرات الاسرائيليه
العسكريه هي تواصل التحليق بشكل مكثف في
مناطق متفرقه من شمال قطع غزه ولكن
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه هذه المدفعيه التي
تتواصل بالقصف على مدار الليله الماضيه
حتى هذه اللحظه في شرق جباليا وفي مناطق
في مشروع بيت لاهيا وبيت لاهيا والى الشرق
وال رب من جباليا ومخيم جباليا هذه
المناطق تتعرض بشكل مستمر بالقصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي و تحديدا منطقه الصفطاوي التي
تحدث العديد من شهود العيان الذي وصلوا من
تلك المنطقه والذين تحدثوا الينا تحدثوا
عن جرائم ارتكبتها قوات الاحتلال في هذه
المنطقه تحدثوا تحديدا عن عدد الشهداء ان
خلال الايام السابقه اخر ما يقرب من سبعه
ايام تعرض هذه المنطقه للعديد من الجرائم
الاسرائيليه تحدثوا عن عشرات الشهداء
والجرحى الذين تركوا ينزفون في الشوارع في
هذه المنطق كذلك تعرضوا ل استهدافات من
قبل القناصه الاسرائيلي الذين استهدفوا كل
من يتحرك وكل من يجدون في هذه المناطق
هذذه الطرقات وكذلك العمارات التي تعرضت
للحرق والتفجير من قبل هؤلاء الجنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وكذلك اعتقال العشرات
من الشبا الفلسطينيين وتم نقلهم الى موقع
زكيم الى الشمال الغربي من بيت لاهيه
وتعرضوا للتحقيق القاسي في هذا الموقع
العسكري الاسرائيلي هذه الاجواء التي في
الميدانيه في شمال قطع غزه وكذلك هنالك
عدد كبير من العائلات عادوا الى منازلهم
ومناطقهم في مشروع بيت لاهيا بعض المناطق
في مشروع بيت لاهيا وكذلك في بعض المناطق
في منطقه تل الزعتر وايضا الى مخيم جباليه
هنالك العديد من العائلات عادوا الى
منازلهم في هذه المناطق التي تحدثنا عنها
ولكن منطقه بيت حنون التي تعرضت ل نكبه
كبيره باستهداف
وتدمير المباني جميع المباني في بيت بيت
حنون تعرضت للقصف والتدمير كذلك للمدارس
والمستشفى الوحيد في هذه المدينه ايضا
تعرضت للتدمير والقصف وايضا الاليات
العسكريه ما زالت تتواجد في المناطق
الشرقيه والشماليه من هذه
عماد بالنسبه للاسر التي عادت الى منازلها
في بعض المناطق ما الذي يواجهونه من ظروف
نتيجه ما خلفه القصف الاسرائيلي
والممارسات
الاسرائيليه قبل قليل كانت لي جوله في هذه
المناطق في مشروع بيت لاهيه وفي منطقه
الزعتر وفي اطراف الشر الغربيه لمخيم
جباليا هنالك حاله من التجريف والتدمير
والخراب في هذه المناطق وكان زلزالا ضرب
هذه المناطق ولكن العائلات هي اصرت الى
العوده الى منازلها او او او ما ما ما
تبقى من تلك المنازل لكن هنالك الاوضاع
المعيشيه هي تزداد سوءا وتتفاقم يوما بعد
بعد يوم الموارد
الاساسيه هي لا تتواجد في شمال قطع غزه
بسبب المنع لمده طويله من دخول المساعدات
الانسانيه الى شمال قطع غزه كذلك شح
المياه لا تتواجد المياه في هذه الم ناطق
وهناك انقطاع للمياه بسبب ايضا انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي بشكل كامل وايضا هنالك
سوء في وانقطاع كامل في الاتصالات
والانترنت في شمال قطاع غزه هناك صعوبه
كبيره في التواصل بين هذه العائلات وايضا
بين اقربائهم في جنوب قطاع غزه وكذلك من
يتواجدون في خارج قطاع غزه هذه الاوضاع
المعيشيه تزداد سوءا بعد سوء هنالك فقدان
ل الدقيق و طحين في المنازل هنالك ايضا ما
يتعلق بالغاز كذلك والوقود هناك انقطاع
كامل في شمال قطع غزه هنالك سوء الاوضاع
المعيشيه لكن رغم هذه الاوضاع المعيشيه
لان ايضا ما يتعرض ما بعض المستشفيات
كمستشفى كم العدوان الان جاري اعاده
وتاهيل هذه المستشفى جزئيا ولكن هناك
صعوبات جمه تواجه القائمين على مستشفى
كمال عدوان مثل النقص الشديد في الوقود
والمستلزمات الطبيه والتدمير الذي واجهته
هذه المستشفى خلال الايام السابقه شكرا
جزيلا لك من مخيم جباليه الصحفي عماد زقوط